discipline definitely does help you with
is it helps you get things done and when
you get things done when you you
actually do things you you you have more
success if you have more success
sometimes a big part of success is just
not being lazy and just doing it yeah
just yeah that's like 90% of it is just
showing up get there and start working
like you're not gonna feel perfect every
day if I felt if I only worked out when
I felt good I'd be a theft because
there's a lot of days I want to do it
through discipline I get things done I
always tell my say that I'm like the
most lazy disciplined person I know
because I don't want to do it yeah but I
always do when you're alone with your
thoughts you get an idea of what your
thoughts actually are if you live your
life just acting constantly on the
momentum of other people's expectations
of you wanting to be liked by these
other people you can run into a trap and
you set up a life that you didn't really
want you're trapped in this situation
where you have a mortgage
you've got credit card bills you've got
student loans you have to pay you have a
bunch going on you have to continue to
feed and especially if you have a family
then you're fully locked in you can't
take any chances and oftentimes people
make the mistake of getting stuck and it
is just a tactical mistake just like it
would be a mistake if you got stuck on a
video game just like it would be a
mistake if you followed a map
incorrectly and you get stuck in the
woods and sometimes you have to back up
and try again and if you're in a
position where you can't back up and try
again you've trapped yourself it's up to
you to see that video game problem to
see that issue as it comes up on the map
to see all the problems that could
potentially lay in front of you and
calculate your your future and then also
look around all the people that didn't
do it and look at the misery that
they're in and learn that you don't want
to be like them and then look at the
people that have kind of taken chances
and navigated their way what do they do
differently than you what what
objectivity do they have that maybe you
lack the person who's able to look at
themselves the closest it's gonna get
the more rational results you just
watched two amazing clips from Joe Rogan
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]